hey whoa guys my name is Regina welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we talked about cameras and we
created an orthographic camera
definitely check out that video if you
haven't already and today in a special
midweek episode we're actually going to
be moving a lot of our code into the
actual sandbox application and I'll show
you a few tricks with how you can kind
of set that up in a bit of a better way
so I just have to make is a midweek
episode just because it's like kind of
like a minor change we're not really
learning anything new which is
refactoring code and moving it around
and so I didn't think it would be fair
to you guys if I just kind of made a new
video on like Sunday as usual and then
it's just like this made a
disappointment not this is gonna be a
major disappointment you should
definitely still watch this video by the
way but um let me know what you think
about midweek episodes in general as we
kind of move on with hazel and we start
doing more and more stuff and it gets
more exciting I might consider doing two
episodes a week so just drop a comment
let me know what you think about that
and I might get that in the future
patron or composer slash the channel is
the best way to support this series
thank you to everyone who made this
series possible if you go ahead and help
support the series there you'll get
access to my private development
repository of hazel in which we've got
much more advanced code and all this
stuff and then you also get videos early
and like you can get access to a private
channel on discord where we kind of talk
about these things in more detail and
you can kind of just essentially help
plan these videos which is really cool
okay so let's refactor our code so last
time we had this whole camera system
position rotation I also gave you guys
some homework to actually see if you
could make the camera respond through
user input and we'll actually do that
today as well that's gonna be the fun
part of today's today's video but what
we need to do first of all is I don't
like that this stuff obviously is inside
application we have a sandbox app if we
look over here it's an actual separate
application this is our exe file hazel
is just a static library at this point
this sandbox app is where everything
should exist so let's talk about how we
can do that because this example layer
this kind of sandbox that we have here
this example that is our game
essentially right and it could be like
just a 3d application doesn't have to be
a game but in this case it's just it
this is kind of our app right this is
our actual application so this is where
all of the code that is specific to this
application should be the first thing I
want to do is clear all this stuff up we
have like example layer which is
fine we have an update which at the
moment just tests out like input polling
so we can get rid of that we also have a
test I'm going around a window which we
donate either amount and then we've got
a non-event when we press a certain key
or whatever it like just you know this
is the kind of responding to events to
input events rather than polling so we
can get rid of all that code because we
don't need any of that now it's going to
enter application and start carrying the
stuff across so this while running loop
is actually kind of what we need so I'll
just cut this all and I'll leave this
stuff here which is basically just layer
updating and also I'm GUI updating this
is our main kind of game loop I guess
our application loop and then over here
I'll just put this into an update now
this isn't gonna immediately work and
we'll have to refer to some code to make
it work so let's go ahead and do that
I'm going to add some private members
into this example layout if we go back
to application it's basically gonna be
everything that we used so we had all
this shared pointer stuff we had the
camera I think that's probably it so the
shader and the vertex array I'll go back
here and we'll add this into our sandbox
app over here as just private fields now
we're gonna need some stuff to clean
this up
hazal should have everything we need we
haven't added stuff to hazel in ages
though so we definitely need to kind of
expand that we found nothing in the
renderer as you can see is here is here
so let's just clean it up so we need to
have hazel render Ella see what's in
here we need to have all this stuff
really so we could have renderer we can
have like render command and again
remember some things will include other
things like for example render command
includes render API right which includes
vertex array so you don't have to
actually put everything in here but it's
good practice to anyway because if I
suddenly remove and include from
renderer that everything else relied on
right I'm gonna have to include it
manually somewhere else is gonna break
my code I don't want that so it's pretty
good practice to say basically that
everything that I definitely know I want
in the actual hazel API to be kind of
public right that stuff should be
included here and
I'm doing this in nor specific order it
doesn't really matter too much
but I'm doing orthographic camera pretty
much everything in that renderer thing
should be exposed render API doesn't
need to be so I'm not gonna add it there
but everything else I think you know
should be graphics context doesn't need
to be either keep in mind that doesn't
mean that because they're not listed
here that they're private obviously
they're not if something else you know
like rendering includes
a render command which includes around
or API Surendra API is actually
accessible it's just not listed here
explicitly that's all because it's not
really needed to be used so I might just
do some but might just put all the power
resources down here let's see so we're
gonna have renderer and render command
base render stuff and there may be like
resources like buffer shader vertex
array and then like other kind of rent
or primitives here right so we kind of
begin to have some stuff the end we
could put like a little divider here if
we wanted to that just kind of lets us
neither
this is renderer related things okay and
I think we need two more dots maybe one
more card to tell yep okay good
cool so there we go we've got our own
rough stuff beautiful so now we need to
actually make sure we're in the hazel
namespace now I could just using
namespace hazel I don't want to because
this is an example and I want to really
kind of just make that point of what is
actually used by the example right so
what is from hazel and what isn't and
currently we just have shared pointers
defined here I think in the future we
are going to actually create a new name
for shared pointers that we can use but
that's gonna be another video we'll talk
about that later so this will also be
like a hazel construct because in the
future we also might want to change it
to something else because we don't want
to kind of rely on this as for memory
management necessarily right okay
orthographic camera is also hazel this
stuff is hazel and so is that okay
brilliant
so now we need to actually create some
of this stuff back in application I'm
gonna steal camera right just
take that and cut it and put it here all
right and then this vertex are a reset
and just pretty much everything that we
have here all of our shaders all that
stuff I'm going to cut it so that our
application constructor goes down to
just being as simple as this right and
I'm going to paste it into now there's a
few places you could put this in you can
see that we have the sandbox control
constructor which does push layer right
and then push layer actually does the
new example layer and runs this code
here however if we try and do that you
might find that it does actually doesn't
work the reason is what actually happens
is this is application right application
constructor well actually it no it
should work because the application
constructor creates the window and does
all of that stuff and only after that's
done because this is a default
constructor so basically it will be
called you know like that essentially
right just first before we push this
layer in it should actually create our
rendering context and everything so it
should be safe to do everything in the
constructor if we wanted to if it's not
then you can always create like an
ornament function that definitely
happens after you know stuff has been
initialized basically so and by stuff
has been initialized I mean specifically
like the computer graphics rendering
context because we obviously can't
create like all of these renderer
resources before we have a context okay
so just bring the hazel yeah again I
could use a namespace but I don't want
to because I want to be really explicit
about what is hazel and what isn't
okay and then we have shader because you
can see it like the clarity that this
kind of gives us right we can see
everything the ball is hazel okay and I
think that's pretty much it let's look
over here in our I don't think we have
anything else really sir that should
just work I think let's just try and run
this code and see what happens okay so
you can see that running that code gives
us the same result as we had in the
previous video so we've successfully
refracted everything and moved it into
the sandbox app class that was really
easy to do now let's go ahead and see if
we can add some kind of like arrow key
input or something to just make our
camera
able to move right so to do that let's
come over here into an event and react
to certain events so this is going to be
a really good example of the event
dispatcher system so if we open up the
event file we can see we have this event
dispatcher with kick which is capable of
dispatching certain types of events so
we're gonna use that by creating the
event dispatcher and it's basically
distinct and instances stack instance of
the dispatcher all right dispatcher
which is gonna take in the event and
then we'll say dispatcher dots dispatch
and then the type of events this is
going to be a hazel key pressed event
right and we're going to use the I think
inside where is it it's like or maybe we
have this hazel bind event function
which is what we kind of want to use
right so this hazel bind event function
and then we're going to give it a
function here so we'll say on the
pressed event and this is gonna be hazel
be pressed event event so what is this
example layout on key pressed event I
think that's it that's all the macro
needs yep great so we just put that in
and now if it encounters one of these
and this is so let's see why that's not
working
what is this batch one an event function
which is function that returns pool okay
so yeah this is void make sure we
returning
bulld okay and yep that error goes away
great so bulwark is whether or not we
want it to like block so because if you
look at application you can see that
what happens is that will go through
every layer and dispatch the event
however if it's already been handled
then we break so we stop dispatching and
we stop propagating it to further layers
with key pressed event like we don't
care can affect everything but we don't
want to block and consume the input it
doesn't matter if your attend to or
false in this case because we don't have
any other layers where key events are
gonna be blocked I think I'm going to
the zone handling so it's not gonna
block it from that anyway but if suppose
we did have like a UI layout and when
you
type in the UI layer you know like you
don't want you know cuz you have like a
text field in your UI you don't want the
character to move if you use that if you
type the WASD Keys because you're
entering text that's at which point
you'd return true when you know when you
want to block that okay so let's check
this out so if event get key code is a
Shahzad key left I guess will move left
right so the way that we'll do that is
we have this camera which is great but
I'm actually going to have a GLM back
three camera position again and we're
gonna start off this camera position
over here inside the constructor as
being just zero right so I think I don't
know if we can supply as you're like
that
and we actually I don't think we can
let's see if ever even compiles because
I think that we need to specifically use
three oh maybe not maybe that will work
yeah okay good
yeah it should so there's a constructor
that just takes a scalar so in this case
right we want to take that camera
position and we want to move it left
right we're moving the camera left so to
do that we just say dot X minus equals a
certain speed so M camera camera speed
will say okay and this will be a float
that we define here for example so flirt
M camera speed we're gonna start it off
as being like 0.1 or something which is
probably gonna be too fast now at the
Merman I mean there's a huge problem
here alright cuz if I mean events get
dispatched every frame right this is
gonna be kind of dependent on our actual
speed of movement actual like rendering
frame rate or how fast our application
runs we do want to use something called
Delta time and most likely I would not
really like you might not want to do
this as an event you might want to just
do this like in the on update function
via polling right and I can show you
guys how to do that as well but to do
that properly we'll need to actually
find out how fast our application is
running and calculate something called
Delta time so that we actually moved the
camera independent of how
fast our application is actually running
because of course even if we have vsync
turned on which would mean that this app
is running at 60 frames per second or 60
updates per second someone has a 144
Hertz monitor for example it'll run at
144 times per second unless it's like
not able to render that quickly so and
we in which case the camera will move
faster so that stuff to think about that
will do in the future but for now really
easy stuff will do key left will do gear
ripe which multi which basically
increments our camera position right and
by the space that we move right and then
up and down is going to do the same to Y
so if we move down we want to move the
camera down so negative and then if we
if we press the uparrow we want to move
it up and then finally what we want to
do is inside on update before we do this
stuff we want to set our cameras
position to be and camera position okay
we won't worry about rotation yet I'll
just leave that as 0 let's hit a 5 and
see what happens ok so here is our app
and if I press left or right you can see
it moves now this is a key pressed event
and E as you can see it's only reacting
when the keys actually pressed and then
repeated right so we get this kind of
really chunky movement it's not really
what we want at all because it's an
event system right it reacts to key
presses it means that I can just be like
blah blah blah blah like I'm pressing
left here right doom doom doom doom doom
and I don't know what's that with these
weird noise I'm making by the way but
anyway it's moving my actual camera got
a mount which is great this stuff is
great for like if you want to navigate
through a menu but if you actually want
smooth in like in engine gameplay or
whatever and you want to actually move
your character or your camera properly
this stuff is rubbish so let's go ahead
and not use an event system and use a
and use out on update function like
you're supposed to okay so let's go over
here into an update and instead of doing
all of this all this stuff we just want
to say if input is P down or is key
pressed HS ed key op or whatever in fact
I'm just going to copy this stuff
because it's gonna be stupid so
instead of writing event.keycode we
instead do is keep rest just like that
boss this is hazel input so we can copy
this and put it all everywhere over here
all right so now what should happen and
we'll obviously get rid of all of this
stuff and in fact I'll get rid of this
completely because we don't need it
right now
and I want to keep this code pretty lean
what we're gonna do now is just hit a
five and now in the update loop whenever
we like if the left case pressed every
single update it will actually move our
camera so this should be completely
smooth and this is the kind of stuff
that you would expect from actual game
so as you can see when I move right now
it moves which is awesome now if you
have a high refresh rate monitor it
might move so quickly that it just moves
off the screen right if you've got least
intend on if you have being turned off
then like rip right this is gonna just
run it a thousand or two thousand four
thousand frames per second and you're
not going to see this at all but you can
see a sixty times per second this isn't
bad okay so that's it we can move our
camera let's see if we can rotate our
camera as well so what I'll do is I'll
just say that if we have oh and by the
way what you probably should do is like
an LC for something for up-and-down
otherwise you can actually end up
canceling each other is like movement so
I'll say that we'll say else if and if
we do that it means that this this key
has precedence over this K which is
usually fine I might say up as
precedence over down there so up moves
it okay cool so there we go so if I must
say if the a key is pressed right we
might say that the rotation camera
rotation which I don't have let's make a
flirt cold and
orientation will set that equal to zero
if we press the a key camera rotation -
equals camera speed I guess you should
probably break this up and have like a
camera rotation speed
so we'll say a camera move speed order
factor this old ship ah with visual
assist camera move
well what I do can remove speed not
camera move rotation camera move speed
and then camera rotation and then camera
rotation speed okay whoops I don't know
how I did that
this is obviously just gonna be that and
I'll do 0.1 for this it's that way we
can have an independent speed for
movement and for rotation so we'll say
camera rotation - equals camera rotation
speed and then with the D key we'll say
that it rotates in a positive direction
okay so let's see what we get here
all right so a and D do absolutely
nothing because of course I forgot to
actually plug in camera rotation into
our rotation we're still setting our
rotation to zero so let's just do that
properly and then see what happens
alright there we go so that a and D
rotate the camera that's very slow
though because it isn't I guess it is in
degrees so we probably want to change
this more to like two or something like
that and furthermore you can see that
you might see that it's actually
rotating it the other way so when I do -
equals camera rotation speed it's
actually rotating it almost looks like
I'm rotating the object instead of the
camera because it should be going the
other way shouldn't it
that's because a positive rotation
actually rotates this way right and a
negative rotation rotates clockwise
that's just the way that it works so
because of that you actually want to do
a plus equals to the camera rotation
speed if we press a and if we wanted to
rotate kind of we want to rotate the
camera left and then minus equals to do
it like a negative rotation if we press
the D key so
let's fix that and press f5 and we
should get this right so now I can
basically move my camera right and I can
rotate my camera and that all works as
you would expect okay so now we have a
moving thing it's kind of hard to tell
because we're just rendering one thing
pretty easy for us to change it I'll
wait it's not because at the moment the
way that we render things is only by our
vertex positions so what we actually
need to do is be able to render objects
in different positions right which we
can't do right now when we submit
something that's it it's just like a
vertex array with this baked vertices
and then the shader
we have no way of saying I want this
object to have this transform so that's
something that we need to do we might do
that next episode the other alternative
is this stuff as I said right now is
bound to actually just be the speed at
which our application is actually
updating we want this to be independent
of that so we need to introduce
something called Delta time and
basically do proper time kind of step
management so that's another option of
what we what we can do probably do one
of those too next time I think I just
want to get Delta time out of the way
because that's something that you know
we should have pretty early on and it
will just enable us to fix all that our
code kind of and make it actually run
for all of you guys properly anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did hit the like button you can also
help support the series by going over to
patreon a call full staff the churner
where you'll get episodes early and
access to the Hale development branch as
I mentioned so we have kind of two
issues two things that I want to do here
today we managed to kind of get
everything out the application plus our
application class is actually clean now
actually let's go back to the
application class because I think that
nono actually did I thought that I
forgot to remove stuff from the header
file but no but pretty good here we can
actually get rid of this hazel API we
don't need that anymore this stuff
includes almost everything
yeah shader buff over text array that's
the stuff I was talking about we don't
need any others includes anymore it's
important to clean up your includes if
you don't need them anymore because
that's something that people often
forget but you can see that our
application class is really nice and
clean again like seventy-nine lines
occurred beautiful and
Alice and box app actually has
everything so that's good because it's
actually an example of us using hazel
engine to actually render something and
even add interaction to it which is
pretty cool
okay so next time we're going to take a
look at Delta time and how that works
and why we need it even in the first
place
and that should be a lot of fun so I'll
see you guys in the next episode good
bye
[Music]